il
et
des temps de tous azimuts les
soviétiques commencent à quitter kaboul
en angola le cessez-le-feu est acquis
pour la guerre iran irak ce n'est plus
qu'une question d'heures
sncf après l'accident de la gare de
l'est la sécurité en question dans les
trains les syndicats ont manifesté cet
après midi à paris
le drame des peuples de la mer du nord
6000 d'entre eux sont morts en quelques
semaines seulement
personne n'est capable de dire pourquoi
reportage formule 1 senna devant
princière le championnat indécis
en fait la saison et ce fut marquée par
l'incroyable domination des mclaren dont
soir il faut être prudent mais l'été 88
restera peut-être dans l'histoire comme
l'était de la détente déjà il y avait
des signes convergents depuis plusieurs
semaines mais ce lundi dans la même
journée deux conflit qui durait depuis
des années sont sur le point de trouver
une solution
en angola le cessez-le-feu semble acquis
on l'a appris tout à l'heure pour la
guerre entre l'iran et l'irak
ce n'est plus qu'une question d'heures
et puis enfin image symbole de cette
journée les soviétiques qui se retire
d'afghanistan depuis un moment déjà les
soviétiques ont commencé à quitter
kaboul la capitale
gilles rabin une poignée de rose
d'afghanistan lancé à ses soldats de
l'armée rouge qui se replient et dont il
faudra bien dire un jour qu'elle a perdu
cette guerre pour la première fois
aujourd'hui conformément aux accords de
genève les soviétiques ont retiré des
trous de kaboul une unité de combat au
grand complet 500 hommes et une centaine
de véhicules blindés qui ont quitté tôt
ce matin la capitale afghane
la gravité des visages de ces soldats
soviétiques exprime la tension ils ont
subi ces derniers jours dans kaboul
presque assiégé par la résistance et
pilonnés 8 et jour gravité et
soulagement cette cérémonie d'adieu qui
se veut populaire et spontanée cache mal
le désarroi des alliés afghans des
soviétiques
pour eux la guerre est finie ou presque
un hélicoptère de combat et mis 26
veillera sur le convoi jusqu'à la
frontière
lundi dernier en effet une colonne
identique a été attaquée alors qu'elle
quittait kandahar la deuxième ville
d'afghanistan dans le conflit entre
l'iran et l'irak une solution pacifique
n'est plus qu'une question d'heure c'est
ce que vient de dire à l'onu le
secrétaire général monsieur perez de
cuellar il a même ajouté qu'aucune
difficulté de dernière minute n'était à
craindre
on sait déjà que monsieur perez de
cuellar veut envoyer 3 150 observateurs
dans la région du conflit
c'est donc peut-être la fin de huit ans
de guerre une des plus longs
et les plus meurtrières depuis 45 louis
carzou j'ai encore besoin d'une ou deux
rencontres avec chacune des parties
mais j'espère bien vous annoncer la date
du cessez-le-feu dans les heures qui
viennent
déclarait ce matin le secrétaire général
de l'onu
aux dernières nouvelles cette annonce
devrait intervenir dans moins de deux
heures
c'est le revirement irakien qui justifie
la confiance de perez de cuellar le
secrétaire général de l'onu qui voit
ainsi la fin d'un marathon diplomatique
interminable le ministre irakien des
affaires étrangères a accepté dimanche
qu'il refusait depuis trois semaines un
cessez-le-feu préalable à des
négociations directes avec l'iran
il aura fallu que les cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité se
porte garant de ces futures négociations
pour que l'irak accepte d'arrêter les
hostilités et de revenir aux frontières
internationales le cessez-le-feu
effectif devrait intervenir dans une
dizaine de jours délai nécessaire à la
mise en place d'observateurs de l'onu 30
150 hommes environ qui auront pour
mission de contrôler la réalité de
l'arrêt des hostilités entre l'iran et
l'irak
enfin la télévision sud-africaine a
annoncé tout à l'heure que le
cessez-le-feu en angola et dans
l'afrique du sud ouest allait entrer en
vigueur dès mercredi
c'est la suite de l'accord conclu à
genève en fin de semaine entre les sud
africains les angolais et les cubes
alors pierre serra un confirmation de ce
vent de paie donc est ce que c'est bien
l'été de la détente
écoutez effectivement pas en traverse
une période faste et on peut penser que
la paix et se profile à l'horizon
notamment donc on vient de le dire entre
l'iran et l'irak
ces deux pays meurtri épuisé par des
années de guerre de haine et de morts en
plus et bien finalement décidé de
s'arrêter de se battre c'est la même
chose en afrique australe ne savez pas
la même latitude dina même situation
entre angolais voulait dire cubain qui
les soutiennent et l'afrique du sud
on va aussi s'est arrêté tout ça avec la
sortie band coup ça c'est très important
mais alors pourquoi justement ces
conflits trouve une solution maintenant
et pas il ya un an ou même avant oui
c'est vrai une vraie question pourquoi
est ce qu'on peut voir si on peut les
arrêter aujourd'hui pour qu'on va plutôt
c'est vrai je crois que simplement la
réponse est très simple kremlin a décidé
d' apaiser les conflits régionaux
regardez en apparaît aussi de
l'afghanistan ne sais pas du tout la
même situation c'est sur le terrain pas
noble armée rouge aurait de le voir se
retire mais sans avoir 20
vraiment se retire peut-être dans des
conditions difficiles n'a pas réussi à
imposer à kaboul un régime assez solide
et les moudjahidine les résistants le
menace le régime est donc ce serait leur
victoire paraît probable dans l'état
actuel des choses ce serait un échec
pour nom soviétique
donc si ça n'est pas les mêmes
situations en tout cas c'est la même
doctrine diplomatique qui prévaut sur le
terrain aussi bien en angola
aussi bien en afghanistan que dans la
guerre du golfe c'est la perestroïka de
gorbatchev qui a décidé finalement
qu'aujourd'hui il valait mieux pour
l'union soviétique au lieu d'alimenter
les conflits de participer à leurs
solutions
merci pierre en france plusieurs
centaines de personnes dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour manifester leur
mécontentement après l'accident de train
de la gare de l'est à l'appel des deux
syndicats cgt et cfdt à paris tout à
l'heure l'accident de samedi a fait je
vous le rappelle un mort et 50 blessés
pour les syndicats les véritables causes
des dernières catastrophes ferroviaires
sont à chercher du côté des économies
budgétaires et des suppressions
d'emplois
pascal deschamps michel levasseur 17h24
la soeur du voyageur tué samedi 100
francs à la gerbe déposée par les
syndicats
elle croyait que c'était celle de la
direction de la sncf avec laquelle elle
est aujourd'hui en français
ces cinémas suffit les blessés graves se
fit
en abaissant de sécurité dans les
transports campagne le droit à la
sécurité a rassemblé ce soir beaucoup de
cheminots mais aussi des usagers
inquiète les syndicats qui participeront
pour la première fois aux travaux d'une
commission denquête ont bien l'intention
avaient proposé des mesures concrètes
un exemple précis sur le matériel c'est
le fait que par exemple lorsque le train
est mis en action de manière inopinée ou
par l'agent lui même que le circuit de
30 jours soit coupée c'est un truc qui
existent sur le tgv question qu'un
certain nombre de matériels n'en
bénéficie pas au delà un exemple anodin
peut être mais qui ment ce qui pourrait
être fait à condition qu'on y mette le
prix est pour nous de cet été on doit y
mettre le prix
l'essentiel en fait c'est que la sncf
supprime 10000 emplois de cheminots par
an et que on arrive forcément à
il constate et ses catastrophes c'est à
dire que un manque de moyens est
forcément forcément une répercussion
pour les usagers non négociées réduction
personnel rentabilité contre sécurité la
direction de la sncf s'en défend jamais
dans sa gestion la sncf n'a sacrifié le
moins du monde la sécurité aux exigences
de la compétitivité
nul doute que la polémique sur le prix
de la sécurité sera au coeur des
discussions entre syndicats et direction
prochain rendez vous jeudi de sécurité
encore on l'a appris aujourd'hui un
cheminot de paris austerlitz a été
écrasé par un train dimanche en fin de
matinée alors qu'il dirigeait une
manoeuvre sur un quai à propos de l'
enquête de la gare de l'est
on ne connaît pas encore les véritables
raisons du drame patrick esther il râle
qui rentrent dépôt pour révision une
scène courante pour la sncf
tous les trente sept jours maximum les
trains subissent un examen mécanique ils
sont l'objet d'une révision générale
après un million quatre cent mille
kilomètres on vérifie les circuits
électriques les roues les freins et les
structures
un travail qui emploie 33 mille agents
durant les dix dernières années le
nombre de ses cheminots a été diminué de
21%
bien sûr que nous faisons des économies
bien sûr que nous n'aimons pas gaspiller
ni le matériel ni les pièces ni les airs
de main d'oeuvre qui sont très chers
mais au-delà de cette économie de cette
absence de gaspillage
croyez bien que nous mettons tout notre
responsabilité et notre honneur à faire
la maintenance sécuritaire absolument
nécessaire telle qu'elle est et même au
delà
le train accidenté n'avait que 4 ans
mais la locomotive semblable à celle ci
qui le poussait était vieille de 20 ans
on sait maintenant que cette machine
était aux deux tiers de sa puissance au
moment du choc
elle poussait le train dont tous les
freins étaient serrés problèmes de
transmission entre la cabine située en
tête du train et la machine accrochant
que ou erreur du conducteur qui
n'auraient pas ramené la manette
moddeurs vers lui c'est à cette question
précise que leur quête va devoir
répondre mais il faut par ailleurs
souligner que le train accidenté n'était
pas munie d'un système coupant
automatiquement les moteurs lors du
déclenchement des freins la sncf a
équipés récemment 1700 locomotive d'un
automate de ce type
malheureusement 4300 machine n'en sont
pas encore revenus
un conflit social en voie de règlement
celui des mines de gardanne il durait
depuis trois mois mais les négociations
qui ont eu lieu tout au long de la
journée au ministère de l'industrie à
paris semble sur le point d'aboutir
il faut dire que seule la cgt refusait
encore de reprendre le travail
nicolas jacobs emmanuel vanier la
délégation le plus attendu aujourd'hui
au ministère de l'industrie celle de la
cgt seul syndicat encore appelé à la
grève à gardanne à la cgt comme aux
autres syndicats les représentants du
ministère de l'industrie ont proposé une
prime de reprise du travail de 15 cents
francs au lieu des 1000 initialement
prévu deux autres primes de 4500 francs
sont également acquise alors qu'à
l'origine l'une d'elles n'était qu'une
avance enfin il n'y aura ni poursuites
ni répercussions financières pour les
grévistes
un train de mesures qui satisfait la cgt
les discussions du nom de 2,2 me conduit
marqué l'évolution très positive dans
les positions et n'avoir c'est très
intéressante par rapport aux 27
toutes les conditions semblent donc
maintenant réunies pour que cesse le
conflit même si les propositions faites
cet après midi ne comporte en fait que
eu d'amélioration elles doivent
permettre à la cgt de sortir la tête
haute de la grève à condition bien sûr
que la base convoqués en assemblée
générale demain acceptent ces
propositions mais sauf surprise ce
devrait être le cas
la joie des mineurs de gardanne après l
annonce des mesures il était 18 heures
sur le carreau de la mine un conflit
long de 4 mois vient sans doute de
prendre fin
voyons maintenant les autres faits de
l'actualité de ce lundi
lundi 8 août 80 8 c'est à dire 8 8 88
c'est une date rare une date célébrée
comme tel aux quatre coins du monde
dans le département des vosges par
exemple c'est le département 88 les
états unis bien sûr d'où viennent ces
images où les américains sont friands de
ce genre de célébration même chose en
allemagne où 130 mille personnes se sont
mariés aujourd'hui cela fait cinquante
cinq mille coupe qui ont choisi cette
date magique pour leur apporter le
bonheur
voici maintenant les plus sérieusement
donc les autres faits majeurs de
l'actualité patrie
arrivé ce matin en bolivie du secrétaire
d'état américain george shultz une
visite officielle de 12h et déjà une
première alerte
l'explosion d'une bombe de forte
puissance sur le passage du cortège pas
de blessé bris de vitre seulement un
attentat non revendiqué pour l'instant
liberté pour deux indépendantistes
kanaks inculpés et écroués après la fac
de la gendarmerie de fayaoué décision de
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de paris
en revanche refusé la même chambre
d'accusation sur 23 autres demandes de
mise en liberté
un canal à 25 nouvelle plainte pour
destruction de biens immobiliers ou
mobiliers des plaintes qui mettent en
cause l'attitude des forces de l'ordre
sur l'île entre avril et juillet dernier
elles s'ajoutent aux 50 déjà déposés par
les habitants d'ouvéa obsèques cet après
midi en corse d'un grand nom de la
résistance henri fresnay
il en a été l'un des principaux
dirigeants après sa démission de l'armée
française en janvier 41 une communiste
niveau liste il avait écrit de nombreux
livres sur cette période en particulier
l'énigme jean moulin
la fin du périple fou pour les 11000
flux toxique du zenobia aujourd'hui à
gênes en italie déchargement pour
retraitement de la cargaison maudite le
zénob il y avait embarqué à milan pour
une errance d'un an et demi gilles
outils le venezuela la sardaigne puis
retour à la case départ c'est 18 marins
avaient été évacués en juin dernier
victime des émanations toxiques le drame
des phoques
c'est l'hécatombe en mer du nord un
tiers de ces animaux sont déjà morts en
quelques semaines
et personne ne connaît la cause de cette
épizootie on sait comment les phoques
meurt on ne sait pas pourquoi
l'hécatombe a commencé jacques doo est
allé enquêter sur les rivages où meurent
les phoques en allemagne du nord et en
hollande par exemple
reportage c'est l'état d'urgence tous
les jours pour cette équipe de bénévoles
vite il faut faire très vite pour sauver
ce jeune phoque qui agonise sur la plage
yann n'est pas vétérinaire mes
instituteurs
il a seulement appris les gestes qui
sauvent ce phoque serait mort un quart
d'heure plus tard
asphyxié victime d'une maladie
pulmonaire mystérieuse
premier geste une sonde pour lui libérer
les voies respiratoires et lui faire
absorber un puissant antibiotique
m
depuis quatre mois 6000 phoques sont
morts atteint d'une maladie inconnue du
un virus un tiers des animaux qui vivent
entre la mer du nord et la baltique
il faut faire vite encore yann alerte le
centre de sauvetage tout est mis en
place pour accueillir le choc malades
peu plus urgents il faut enrayé
l'infection il faut surtout éviter toute
contamination urgence aussi on doit
faire tomber la fièvre à 35° à tout prix
laurent
certains présente tous les symptômes
d'une infection généralisée
ils n'ont que très peu de chances de
survie
les plus faibles refuse de s'alimenter
alors on les aide en cas samedi nous
travaillons nos vétérinaires et des
hollandais qui cherchent un vaccin pour
sauver les phoques
tout cela sans argent et sans aide
officielle on signale des animaux
malades partout le long de la côte
le centre est maintenant débordés même
les îles voisines envoi par avion des
animaux retrouvés sur les plages vite
encore
on intervient dès l'arrivée de l'avion
regardez sa bouche pleine de sens il
peut plus respirer c'est dégueulasse
beaucoup meurent dans une agonie très
pénible
mais pour les plus faibles une chance
l'avion spécial les emmène au centre
hôpital de peter buren en hollande
cet hôpital est spécialisée dans
l'accueil des phoques il est le seul en
europe
celui-ci affaibli par la maladie a eu
l'oeil crevé par les oiseaux
mais il est sauvé ici tout est axé sur
la recherche pour trouver un vaccin
contre le virus
30 phoques sont touchés par la terrible
maladie l'isue eder la vétérinaire de
l'établissement a mis au point un vaccin
mais il faut encore quinze jours de
tests pour connaître son efficacité ne
vaut pas de solution pour sauver les
phoques
je pense que l'on devrait préserver la
mer la nettoyer mais il n'ya pas non
plus de solution sur tout ce que je peux
faire c'est chercher la mer du nord on
le sait est une véritable poubelle mais
personne ne sait si elle a donné
naissance à ce mystérieux virus
1200 phoques sont morts la semaine
dernière si milan 4 mois sur 16000 que
comptent les pays scandinaves
certains disent les scellés fois campé
les plus forts survivront de même
autre épisode si beaucoup moins grave
heureusement celle des lapins dans les
vosges moins grave parce que plus
localisées aux contreforts du massif
montagneux
nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière dans ce journal mais cette fois
le mystère semble sur le point d'être
éclairci les spécialistes pensent avoir
trouvé le responsable rémi roche
le mystère est en grande partie levé ni
pollution ni empoisonnement encore moins
mauvais sort c'est une bactérie qui est
à l'origine de la mort de quelques 2500
lapin jean paul maurice l'un des
meilleurs spécialistes de la question en
a aujourd'hui la certitude
au terme de plusieurs jours dans quête
sur le terrain il s'agit en l'occurrence
de ce qu'on appelle une septicémie
hémorragique c'est-à-dire maladie
absolument foudroyante qui met son lapin
aka répit de quelques heures et maladies
connues anciennement d'ailleurs comme
étant due à une bactérie également connu
et bactéries dont le nom et pastore la
mildt au sida semblablement reste à
savoir pourquoi ces bactéries que l'on
rencontre couramment sans conséquences
fâcheuses c'est de nombreux animaux
pourquoi la pasteure est là est devenu
soudainement responsable de pareille
hécatombe de nouvelles analyses
actuellement en cours devrait rapidement
l'expliquer et dès lors permettre
l'élaboration d'ici une quinzaine de
jours d'un vaccin spécifique car sans
être alarmiste les spécialistes ont pris
la sphère très au sérieux
pas question que l'épidémie ou plutôt
l'épizootie comme disent les
vétérinaires sortent du périmètre des
quelques claqué deux fermes concernées
pour éventuellement gagner les élevages
intensifs qui sont pour l'instant
totalement préservée les seuls qui sur
le plan politique s'occupe vraiment
d'écologie et les problèmes de pollution
ce sont ce que l'on appelle les verts
justement ils s'étaient réunis ce
week-end dans la haute-loire mais leurs
préoccupations étaient cette fois plus
politique qu'économique cette fois leur
souci c'est multiplier par dix le nombre
de leurs élus aux prochaines municipales
laurent buissière 300 écologistes qui
planche pour étudier la gestion
municipale
c'est une image insolite mais c'est
l'image qui correspond à la nouvelle
stratégie des verts
profitant de la dynamique donnée par la
médiatisation des élections
présidentielles les amis d'antoine
waechter vols multiples
les barques disent leurs élus dans les
conseils municipaux les élections
municipales sont de toute façon des
élections qui nous intéresse au premier
chef est évidente c'est au niveau de la
base au niveau des communautés communal
que l'on peut mener finalement une
politique écologique et je crois que
d'une manière générale les françaises et
les français sont très sensibles aux
propositions que les verts formule pour
améliorer la qualité de vie
particulièrement dans l'espace urbain
dix mille candidats aux élections
municipales avait comme objectif que
3000 d'entre eux soit élu quatre ou cinq
sièges au parlement européen en juin
prochain pour les verts l'année 89 sera
l'année de tous les espoirs
ou celle de tous les dangers puisque
nous sommes au chapitre politique cette
information les négociations traînent
pour la nouvelle calédonie les
délégations du rpcr et du fln caisse ne
viendront pas à paris ces prochains
jours comme prévu il semble que les
discussions soient difficiles en ce
moment à nouméa entre le fln ks et le
haut commissaire le ciel va t'il nous
tomber sur la tête c'était la crainte
des gaulois c'est encore notre crainte à
tous quand on sait que le satellite
nucléaire cosmos pourrait retomber et
sur la france justement c'est un
satellite soviétique dont on a perdu le
contrôle
en fait il y a très peu de chances
qu'ils arrivent sur notre pays
heureusement une chance sur mille
et puis il peut se passer encore
beaucoup de choses pierre-andré lac ou
deux manoeuvres peuvent encore éviter
aux satellites cosmos 19/100 de retomber
sur terre
d'abord une mise en orbite sur très
haute altitude et en cas d'échec une
destruction partielle mais le succès
n'est pas garanti et le risque de voir
un fragment comme le réacteur nucléaire
s'écraser subsistent
la france fait partie des régions
survolé par cosmos et elle pourrait
subir cette éventualité
a toulouse le centre national d'études
spatiales suit la trajectoire de cosmos
pour trait tenter de re prévoir le lieu
d'impact éventuel la probabilité que ce
soit sur le sol français est faible
si le satellite rendre l'atmosphère est
si retombe ensuite au sol parce que
rentrer ça va arriver et il restera
quelque chose au niveau du sol
à ce moment là la probabilité pour la
france c'est sa superficie ses environs
des milliers cependant toute une
procédure de récupération organisé par
le ceva est prévu dans le cas d'un tel
accident intervient à plusieurs titres
il intervient dans la détection
aéroporté des zones susceptibles d'être
atteintes
il intervient ensuite au sol pour
localiser précisément ces débris pour
les neutraliser récupérer des débris les
mettre en conteneurs et puis les stocker
dans des centres du ceva durée totale de
l'opération quelques heures
reste à attendre maintenant la chute du
satellite si elle a lieu elle devrait
dit-on se produire dans trois mois
senna devant prost s'était tiers au
grand prix de formule 1 de budapest
cette fois le championnat est relancé
les deux hommes sont à égalité au
classement mais ce qu'il faut retenir
surtout c'est le nouveau doublé de
mclaren mclaren invaincu mclaren
imbattable mclaren superstar lionel
chamoulaud
j victoire pour ayrton senna 4 pour
alain prost dix grands prix 10 victoires
dont sept doubles et la domination
mclaren est totale
l'écurie britannique une fois encore
sera championne du monde un succès
insolent qui prend forme ici en
angleterre dans les tout nouveaux locaux
tag mclaren une usine ultra sophistiqué
ou 130 personnes créent dessine fabrique
les meilleures formules 1 du moment
un véritable laboratoire de recherche
une structure exceptionnelle
le maître des lieux
c'est lui ron dennis un personnage
complexe mal connus difficile à cerner
c'est un homme d'affaires redoutable la
réussite de son équipe ne n'étonne pas
le budget de l'équipe me permet d'avoir
les deux meilleurs pilotes
le meilleur moteur ils meilleurs
ingénieurs il faut tout cela pour gagner
en formule 1 dans le détail le
responsable technique c'est lui gordon
murray
chaque pilote à son ingénieur le moteur
c'est bien sûr le fabuleux honda turbo
depuis deux saisons les japonais sont au
sommet des millions de dollars sont
engloutis pour mettre au point cette
arme suivie depuis le japon sur tous les
circuits du monde grâce à semur
d'ordinateurs bien protégé dans les
stands
et puis il y à prost et senna de pilote
exceptionnel et de metteur au point hors
pair ron dennis avait annoncé un
sans-faute 16 victoires sur cèze le vent
cela n'est possible
voyez c'est possible je crois que je
crois même qu'il ya pas tellement de
raison pour que ça ne se passe pas
ne pas gagner tous les grands prix ce
serait éventuellement une casse
mécanique
ce dont je ne pense pas vraiment
facilité aussi grâce aux planches à
cyclomoteur absolument extraordinaire la
seule chose qui pourrait nous empêcher
ces petites sorties de route ou
accrochage entre les deux par exemple en
tout cas cette merveilleuse voiture
permettra à senna ou à droite d'être
champion du monde le brésilien pour
l'instant tient la corde
il reste six grand prix enfin pour
terminer pour tous ceux qui aiment la
poésie c'est un jour de deuil
aujourd'hui on vient de l'apprendre il y
à quelques minutes félix leclerc est
mort le poète et chanteur québécois
avait 74 ans était lui l'auteur des feux
du fameux moi mes souliers et puis de
beaucoup d'autres chansons il avait été
aussi l'un des premiers canadiens
s'imposer en france
gérard dalmaz je dois beaucoup à une
famille de sept frères et soeurs qui
s'appelle do ré mi fa sol la si le
canadien de la guitare un des gros noms
de la francophonie et le barde nationale
des célèbres jardins de neige le baryton
à la voix douce est parti sur la pointe
des pieds
le p'tit bonheur s'est éteint mais tout
le monde le garde dans son coeur
c'est beau la plaque
tu l'a écrit sur moi c'est bon séjour
le grand poète et chansonnier québécois
félix leclerc est donc décédé ce matin à
son domicile de l'île d'orléans près de
québec à l'âge de 74 ans à la suite de
complications cardiaques
le
la mort aussi de francis ponge lui ils
étaient français mais à linverse
beaucoup plus connus à l'étranger
c'était un très grand poète il mort à
l'âge de 89 ans il a écrit toute sa vie
en exerçant une douzaine de métier il
laisse de très beaux textes dont le plus
connu est sans doute le parti pris des
choses et pour terminer ce journal et
bien justement je vais vous citer deux
lignes de lui extraites de ce recueil
justement le parti pris des choses l'on
devrait pouvoir à tout poèmes donné ce
titre raison de vivre heureux voilà je
crois une belle définition de la poésie
fin de ce journal
merci d'être resté avec nous tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec la
météo de cabrol et puis en fin de
programme vers 23h30 un peu au delà
aubry de l'air pour la dernière édition
excellente soirée sur antenne 2